so one of the reasons why our brain
likes to create habits is because our
brain is lazy and the more it automates
a habit it does it without even thinking
about it there are certain habits you
need to have as an entrepreneur that's
automatically you're not even thinking
twice about it or needing to have a
to-do list about it which we'll get into
in a minute but before I do it I want
you to understand that the title seven
Habits of Highly Effective entrepreneurs
came from the famous Stephen Covey book
seven Habits of Highly Effective People
which is be proactive begin with the end
of mind put first things first think
win-win seek first to understand before
you understood and then it's energized
and last but not least sharpen the saw
if you haven't read the book you gotta
read it so let's talk about the seven
Habits of Highly Effective entrepreneurs
first things first
on the habit always be aware of the
evolution of a business let me explain
to you what it is on the evolution of
the business whenever a business starts
the book that explained this the bestest
barbarians two bureaucrats it explained
there's always a profit there's the
visionary I have an idea what if we do
that thought that I have an idea what if
I go into this industry have an idea
what if we do this here then there's
barbarians which barbarians are the guys
I want to get it done we're going to go
do this no matter what and that could be
you you could be the proper tender
barbarian then you have the Builder
explore then you start hiring admin
people paperwork compliance and then if
you're not too careful the company
eventually gives birth to bureaucrats
and aristocrats and bureaucrats and
aristocrats are deadly to any society to
any company to any business if you don't
pay attention to so what do I mean by
this you could possibly end up being
that bureaucrat or aristocrat so
bureaucrat or an aristocrat is too cool
for the game it's too cool to be reached
you know it's too cool to be contacted
nobody can get close to them because
you're above everybody so you control
there's a cuckoo like eh don't get close
to me I'm famous don't get close to me
I'm too I'm too important of a person
and as you lose touch with the people
and you lose touch with the population
you become godlike and anytime you
become godlike no one is godlike you're
bound to get killed
and either that business gets killed or
you get killed you just saw what
happened uber recently when the guys at
the top said we are the biggest IPO of
all time etc etc boom too big for
drivers to cool for employees too famous
to popular and they have a fall and next
thing you know what do you call it a
lift goes from having 850,000 rights per
day the day the announcement was made
with Travis getting fired 230 days later
1 million rides a day they went up 20
percent in 30 days simply because
lubbers started experiencing this
bureaucrats who were too crass type of
stuff so the habit is always know what's
next
always know what's going on but keep it
cool to make sure you don't experience
that part next one number two always
have a now you pour Talent this is a
habit you're always out there let's just
see you at dinner somebody starts
talking you'll say I'm impressed by this
guy hey what a new John Deere looking I
want to compliance guy I want to finance
guy you know the Director of Finance
that I had here she helped open up my
checking account at WaMu years ago and
there was a mama we've heard they went
out of business and chase bata for one
point nine billion ten years ago wama
was worth no.5 wom'n was worth three
hundred thirty billion she was my banker
so I go and I open up the checking
account and I said guys this checking
account just opened up it's a future
billion dollar company about his life
and I'm you know you're so crazy you're
going to know about this account that
we're opening up here she kept paying
attention to the account year and a half
later I recruit her she becomes my
Director of Finance but I watched her
every time I wonder how she treated me
everywhere you go watch everybody see
how they treat you the habit of a highly
effective entrepreneurs you're always
looking for talent what if we get this
girl here what if we get this guy here
what did we get this person here I like
the way this guy treats me I like the
way this guy gives me customer service
through constantly thinking about Talent
number three always solving for x
yesterday I was in Cancun having
breakfast with a couple who was thinking
about moving their business from
currently right now they're in LA they
were thinking about whether to go to
Lafayette Louisiana or whether to grow
their business to Miami Florida and so a
what do you think should we do should we
not do it we're thinking about that so
let me ask you a question here
first of all let's solve for X I said
what is solve for X I said it do you
have family back at home
we got a kid and we got a kid we got two
sons here get 1618 okay
location son economy market I said
what's the most important he said our
kids are already grown they're going to
be fine I said so that's not what you're
solving for because if that's the case
you have to stay in LA not at all
location market is what we're solved if
I said then you can't allow Fiat 126
thousand people living there my am you
got a bigger market within a 50 20 mile
radius you may want to start thinking
about Miami that's exactly what we're
thinking about cool no problem so we
solve for X when you don't solve for X
you don't always make the best next
decision or the best next move that you
need to make us you're not thinking what
am i solving for am i solving for value
of profit right now am i solving for
short-term or long-term solution it's
this idea that we just got a good idea
for today for six months from now or
five years from now why are we spending
so much time on an idea that will do
five years from now we don't have the
resources for this three million dollar
idea let's set it aside that's solving
for x so how do you have it of always
solving for x number four constantly
studying data I love studying data
because to me one of the jobs of a CEO
is I need numbers so when I have numbers
I can see what we've done quarter to
quarter to quarter I can see what we've
done month amount to month I can see
what's our best selling day what's our
worst selling day what can we do to
change the worst selling day what's the
next you know data that we need to study
to be able to improve to help the
revenues go a little bit higher grown to
a new market that we're not in
everything is data sometimes I think
people don't look at data too much
because they say I'm an a-type
personality I'm the guy that just goes
out there and gets the job done and I'm
a killer and I'm a visionary I don't
deal with the minutiae ooh
CEOs typically of public companies or
CEOs because they have to do the
quarterly cars calls and investors want
to know why did the stock go up or down
this quarter and the CEO has to do the
quarterly earnings you have to have a
story for all the investors that's why
that person is a CEO so you as the
entrepreneur have to start thinking like
that and the only way you can start
thinking like that is by constipating
attention to the data of your business
whatever that business is number one
the casting govision Jessica here told
me as we were talking she said you know
what Pat every time we're in meetings or
whatever you always say you know 10
million 10 million 10 million she's
saying 10 million 10 million 10 million
where this could go to what I could go
to I can't help myself
but I wasn't like that at first I was
just a dreamer without a vision once I
sit there and I saw 4x and I process the
vision and what its going to get to take
it what it's going to take to get there
I'm constantly selling the vision I'm
constantly selling division in meetings
in conference calls in appointments in
conferences we have no matter what it is
I am constantly selling the vision and
by the way this is not something that's
on the to-do list because I've done it
so many times it's automated in my brain
because it's a habit and because our
brain likes to be lazy because the like
step things being automated I
automatically non-constant going to be
canceling a vision so you highly
effective entrepreneur constantly cast a
vision of where you're going next where
is the company the business where are
you going next
next point constantly again there's
three constantly feared constantly a
staying focus for the next strategy I
don't put the word focused here constic
staying focus for on the next strategy
let me explain to what I mean by this I
did a video something to do with
business strategy how to have a strata
strategize your business etc etc maybe
we should put a link of it so we know
what the title is as they put it up you
know what the link is the thumbnail is
and you can go on the link on the bottom
and watch that as well if you haven't
yet and in this video I describe what is
the role of an entrepreneur okay what is
the role of a CEO who's building a
business okay and a lot of times he was
inviting me to be doing this I need to
be nigh finally wanted to create a
system where everybody knows this is
what you're doing and sometimes you look
at businesses that grow like this or
they stay flat and sometimes you notice
businesses that are growing like this
where they're beating quarter after
quarter after quarter but the top-line
revenues being in the prior quarter what
is going on there and there's a level of
focus and you can do this as well so you
come up with a strategy how do you come
up with a strategy here's the four
brackets the top
is exponential growth the bottom is a
linear growth think about this as the
foundation you build it on but this is
how much you can scale the skyscraper to
be big so you need foundation yes but
then this is what blows up and it grows
it to levels that you can do if you just
focus your linear growth is when you
only focus on operations systems things
like that this death is also linear
relationship I'm talking to this person
talking that but it's important it helps
you but it's linear exponential is when
you come up with your next innovative
campaign you could be the next
innovative campaign could be you know
Tesla could say we're coming out with
this new you know Tesla SUV the doors
open like this it's our next innovative
campaign boom they sell a few hundred
thousand of those cars right
you could have a Nordstrom's could come
up with a next innovative champion
Amazon could come up with their next
innovative campaign be part of prime you
pay this much money per year to get
shipping free this is this free it's
their next innovative campaign companies
constantly come up with their next
innovative campaign could be a sale it
could be it could be contest could be a
lot of different things and then it's
leadership development a business grows
when there's leadership development the
more you focus on your next strategy it
takes a few hours to sit down and do
this and so how do we need to improve
operation how do we need to improve this
death here's what we need here's one
without that okay great what is our next
innovative campaign what's the last ten
months we do which one did the best
which one didn't do well which one cost
us a lot of money which one made us a
lot of money leadership development who
do I need to work on at the home office
to build them into an executive who
which partner do I need to work on
closely to make them a bigger part in a
preferred partner which sales person do
I need to work on because that person
could be a sales leader they can be a
senior vice president or somebody else
who can I lock on to to make that happen
those things is what gets the company to
grow thicker and exponentially so stick
to your strategy and by the way before I
get into my seventh point if you have
any questions thoughts comments on
anything I covered comment on the bottom
I'm not done with the video yet I'm
about to give you the seven point and if
you haven't subscribed to the channel
yet do me a favor and click on the
subscribe button here to subscribe to
the channel before I finish off the
video and if you want to join the
notification squad click on the button
right Nick so now let me give you the
seventh point
here's a 7-point exercise health and
energy that is a habit why if you don't
have energy you cannot last long if you
cannot last long you will be crushed by
another person that knows how to last
long to do all of this stuff that I just
covered with you the word constantly
means what energy constantly means over
and over and over and over and over
again if you don't have energy you can't
do anything constantly you can only do
it once because you need energy this
word
needs energy this word needs energy this
word needs energy always needs energy
always needs energy being aware needs
energy this is I got to be aware it
always needs energy right if you don't
have energy you can't compete in a
capitalism market you can't just cannot
because your brain doesn't have the
energy to think about the next ideas to
come up with so having said that those
are the seven Habits of Highly Effective
entrepreneurs again questions thoughts
comments comment on the bottom if you
haven't sub do so but the challenge I
have for you is this here's what I want
you to do with the ending of this video
I want you to look at all these habits
write them down and ask yourself how
good of a job do you do on every single
one of them and you may want to watch
this video all over again to hear me
explain it to you again and if you got
an executive team you may want to watch
this with them to get them on the same
page as well so you grow even faster
with that being said thanks for watching
and body
[Music]